là où ça bouge nous sommes ce soir sur
la scène du zénith de caen qui propose
ce soir à 20 heures demain 15 heures et
demain soir à 20 heures la légende du
roi arthur nouvelle comédie musicale
c'est parti
ce qui est formidable c'est que ça va
être magique là il vient juste de
descendre du bus de but mais est ce que
vous vous sentez vos pouvoirs assez
puissant ben je sens mes pouvoir se
développer doublement parce que j'ai
comme une magie d'origine ici alors
justement dessus alors expliquez nous
votre parcours canet alors mon parcours
carnet ben ça me fait bizarre de revenir
ici parce que je retrouve mes bancs
d'école sur tout mais bon à la fac
oui je suis venu un petit peu quelques
mois la faculté de caen moi ma famille
habite pas loin bretteville-sur-odon il
va être rude sinclair il un peu partout
à cherbourg aussi parce que je suis né à
cherbourg
le normand est magique well nos rangs et
magique mais les normands et mystérieux
en même temps ils révèlent pas tous ses
secrets
pendant tout le trajet tout le 18 mai
lors en est on arrivé chez toi oui alors
comment ça se passe alors il ya des
espaces comme ça le public et est
extraordinaire mais je livre pas tout
parce que vous savez les normands
restent normand
ça
toujours dans les coulisses de la
légende du roi arthur au zénith de caen
aujourd'hui et demain plus de 300
costumes vont être utilisés j'en profite
pour dire aussi ce qui se passe ailleurs
notamment demain soir argentan au quai
des arts
avec la venue de l'humoriste belge alex
vizorek extract a parlé de deux morts à
manille c'est un film unique unique dans
l'histoire de l'adaptation littéraire
c'est le seul fils c'est plus rapide de
lire le devant la scène de la légende du
roi arthur au zénith de caen ce weekend
ya trois représentations il reste encore
des places
vous pouvez en profiter je voudrais vous
annoncer le festival pour le jeune
public ribambelle c'est à blainville sur
orne jusqu'au 20 mars
et il ya un spectacle dimanche à 17h qui
s'appelle à l'ombre d'eux nos peurs qui
s'effrite kick ass qui grincent
on vient d'apporter quelques éléments
concernant la légende du roi arthur on
est devant la scène c'est impressionnant
parce que ça fait 26 mètres de long sur
8 de hauteur il ya 45 artistes 40
techniciens c'est vraiment une énorme
équipe 12 camions pour monter ce décor
bref ce sera à grand rendez vous donc ce
soir
également demain 15 heures et demain à
20 heures
et puis je voudrais vous annoncer on va
revenir au quai des arts à argentan qui
est très dynamique en ce moment avec un
concert de jazz mardi prochain c'est
guillaume perret 1,10 electric epic et
un concert de jazz très électrique donc
j'aimerais qu'au merlin nous disent là
où ça bouge
alors je vous dis avec grande passion et
grand amour là où ça bouge il faut être
là où ça bouge